I think we probably got to smash the
two-party system because both the
parties that we've got are making a
terrific mess of it and I don't quite
see how the Labour Party is going to
come back from this and I certainly
don't see how my own party the
Conservative Party is going to come back
from it and for that we might have to
move from a first-past-the-post system
to something more proportional which
gave smaller chances a chance to breathe
but in the immediate well what we got to
do is stop brexit I still think we can
and I still think there's a decent
chance that we will but would you mean
by stopping brexit Amy and also how
would you achieve that is it by a second
referendum yeah it would be by a second
referendum it's got to be by a second
referendum you can say as Jeremy Corbyn
does it's got to be or should be by a
general election fine have a general
election but in the end I want a
government that wants us to leave and I
don't think any government I want a
government that wants us to stay yeah
yeah I didn't need to be with the
spectator ages ago a podcast and someone
said so you're saying we're all racists
everyone's racists are you and I said
yes I want all the people that troll me
on online commentary say Matthew Parris
believes we're all racist anyway I want
a government that keeps us in the
European Union I don't think any
government could or should do that
without getting endorsement from the
people I want a second referendum
therefore because we've had a referendum
it said leave and if we're not to leave
we got to ask the people their
permission to change our minds what if
they don't give it then we well then we
leave I mean every every nation has a
right to self harm I think my argument
would be that when we said leave as by a
slim majority I don't think we had
really thought through or new or
been informed of just what that was
going to mean and how difficult it was
going to prove we have been informed of
that we do know if we still say leave if
we still say well we're prepared to
crash out without a deal and take our
chances it is a democracy we just have
to accept that and what would you say to
those people so what you are wishing to
do the second referendum is undemocratic
and you're essentially ignoring my voice
simply because it is not palatable or
mainstream well I would say I'm not
ignoring your voice you can vote in the
second referendum and let's see how many
people vote how many ways okay you that
if you take a single snapshot of public
opinion in 2016 it won't be long till
that's four years ago you can't then say
it you can never go against that
snapshot opinions change
[Music]